I'm not doing [ __ ] to take those braces
off I don't know why why would you never
wear why would you put them in when you
have to entertain people hi because I've
decided why but during applaud can you
tell that I have them on no my shitty
I'm fairy I'm keeping the mic in front
of my mouth hey don't make me feel
self-conscious man I don't want to I
don't want to do this no I can't do the
podcast with brace Brian you told me I
should start wearing them or not while
we're doing a show babe you can tell
that I'm wearing them that's and that's
ridiculous came from being ridiculous
can't work with brace Brian okay I can't
work with brace brace well you why would
you go to Hooters for the food how was
he cold there Hey look hotter day I'll
go it for that tittays and the chicken
wings
other than that you don't [ __ ] with it
all right you don't [ __ ] with it cuz
then Twin Peaks came on went hold up
we're gonna take this model of hot
chicks serve legit food and beer and
have you know girls with big titties
cuz I'm time you go up to Hooters you go
to Hooters I've been there forever
there just be one across from high
altitude we used to train in Aurora all
the time
so we'd go there but that for whatever
reason there's like I don't have big
titties to work here anymore you know
they can't do that he was discrimination
I think they had a lawsuit against them
so awesome these flat chested bronze
starts showing up you know what sighs
Omar wants me sometimes equal Ryan
writes suck cuz you know Boy Scouts are
now allowing Girl Scouts in a girl's
let's reduce Boy Scouts are now water
soap there is now like souls are allowed
like what do we do if I had a bar called
big dicks right like the big dicks and
you could see dicks and girls showed up
and it was all small dicks like what
right black truffle I want black
truffles no I got that I got you covered
on that those are a little easier to get
a little easier to get into lish got you
covered at it in the light well there's
nothing quite see you're paying for that
unique flavor where you go oh this
smells and tastes like nothing I've ever
had that's that's kind of what you're
doing and then but you can't go crazy if
you like this I feel like there's some
cheese that can compete with a white
truffle I got nice cheese and beautiful
shaved cheese and pew smells like that
not as expense I don't entirely disagree
I don't entirely disagree I've had
cheese's it'll change your whole [ __ ]
life oh right
I mean sometimes cheese so I went to my
friend's place and they had some
uses out and I went why I love that man
I love that my Nana used to make her own
gravy she would always I was saying the
CEO did like when we you know was just
my mom in the house so when my Nana
would be there everyday we get home from
school and we'd be like can we eat were
starving and every time there was pasta
she'd have the gravy going and she
looked get over here and she'd take a
piece of bread and just dunk it in the
sauce and then put it on a plate with a
fork
yeah how good was that Oh insane we
would get in there with the bread forget
it
so wait do you have a recipe then for
your sauce it's a beast to cook your own
sauce no I don't have it I my sauce my
pieces but if I'm like your own pizza
yeah I can't do it all the time like you
have to just like when Rao's is on sale
at Whole Foods for 399 I'm gonna buy
like I mean I love that you have this
vast knowledge yeah so do you make your
own sauce I mean I just want to get back
to it well he threw his mom in my face
and his grandmother and then a little
scurvy tale that's probably a TED talk
it's right TED talk no you know what did
I um I don't mind my wife my wife cooks
I'm so masculine do that box yeah so for
me what do you do for sauce in the house
my wife
your wife's making sauce you know hold
on I pity counts of no times I'll tell
you right now they're [ __ ] buying out
the bottle Hey yeah excuse me your wife
ain't making no homey sauce that never
happened she actually doesn't have to be
fair to her she actually does she'll be
mad if she hears this and I don't give
her credit she does make her own sauce
my mother though if I were to call my
mother and say how to give me the recipe
it'd be it'd be game over okay that's
best it's rare though you find someone
making sauces these days yeah cuz you
can buy good bottled sauces